[Music]
what are the risks that you
foresee on the horizon
and this is a common question i'm going
to ask it because i think people will be
interested in your answer how much do
you worry about sort of regulatory
overstep
or shutdown as we've seen what's
happened in china of course china is not
the united states
but
how concerning for someone who invests a
lot
or for a firm that invests a lot in
crypto
and blockchain is
the regulatory side of things honestly
i'm very much looking forward to
regulation i think it's going to be a
great thing the lack of clarity around
how to treat certain types of asset
assets in this world is what's holding
it back i i believe you know there's
there's
i i don't think the the big question to
ask here is the one like you hinted at
with china where is it does the us wake
up one day and say
actually cryptocurrency is illegal shut
it all down
and i just can't see that being the case
here well it's too far entrenched in
into everything that we're doing um
every
major bank whether they like it or not
is now embracing blockchain in some
capacity it's a fantastic underlying
technology so
it would just be odd to say we're
banning a certain type of technology
like i just can't see that happening in
the united states yeah i i hope that
there's more clarity because a lot of it
is very confusing right now and and to
be fair a lot of it's being defined in
real time
so you know we
don't know how to handle
certain types of assets like there's
there's just weird things coming out of
this like i'll give you an example
there's a protocol called alchemics
that are these self-repaying loans
it sounds nuts but in the world of defy
what does that mean
it's it's crazy so
basically what i could use some of those
self-repaying loans well basically what
it does is it goes out and you come in
and you take a certain amount of
cryptocurrency let's just say it's ten
thousand dollars right
and they take that entire principle
and they go invest it into yield
generating protocols that are out there
in this world of decentralized finance
and they instantly give you half of it
back into straight let's just call it a
stable coin like a us dollar stable coin
so you take ten thousand they give you
five thousand to go do whatever you want
with and because of the yield that
they're able to generate on the entire
principle
they take all the interest payments and
pay it back into the loan so that the
pays itself off automatically
and you're at the current rates it's a
little over two years and the loan just
automatically
pays itself
back so you're receiving your interest
payments up front if that makes sense
but this is only something that would be
possible in the world of defy where
you're having smart contract work with
smart contract and not in traditional
lending it just wouldn't make sense
because you're taking all of the benefit
and giving back to the customer and in
traditional lending when you have mal's
defeat as i mentioned with the wells
fargo example
they would never give you that full
yield back right well they can't do it
right they can't exactly
so this is like but what the wheel yeah
they're only making a mere 72 billion
right exactly and the odd thing though
is like these
repayments
are happening in
near real time
back to the paying down the loan in near
real time
and so talk about like all these little
micro transactions that are occurring
over that two two years and change now
how do you treat those repayments who's
paying them and where are they coming
from and what's your cost basis and you
can imagine like it just makes you go
across that like no one in the irs is
going to tell you how to do this like
there's this has never been defined
before
so
and
and how do you even file something like
that with the irs to explain to them
what you're doing i mean even handling
basic crypto stuff right now with
with filings is very challenging right
you can do it but it's it's very
involved so there's some very
sophisticated financial
just these these new tools these new
um types of code that is being deployed
in these smart contracts and we don't
really have a clean way to even report
them you know let alone understand how
to
what tax rate we should be charged so i
i don't know i i'm excited for some of
the more regulation to come into place i
think that but you ask your question
just to remove the uncertainty so even
if the rules are stringent and punitive
in some respect at least the rules will
be
clarity yeah
i want to pay my taxes i don't want to
go to jail i just don't know how quite
to do it right well i wasn't implying no
no i'm just saying i'm just saying in
the world of deep
protest
i'm saying too much in the world of d5
this is what people are running into is
they don't know how to handle this stuff
so
it's a very exciting space but it's a
very kind of bleeding edge you know um
you know enter at your own risk kind of
world i to answer your question of like
what am i scared of what are the risks
that are out there i think uh there's a
few
one is you mentioned the regulation side
that that's certainly one that kind of
is off there lingering in the background
which
i'm not so much worried about the
what's going to happen on the u.s but
i'm worried about what if another
country bans it
because that causes some instability in
the markets when other countries ban it
which would be the most
impactful countries were they to ban
crypto
outside of china are there any countries
that stand out that one might not expect
so outside of the us like who are the
players who would really move the
markets yeah that's a good question i i
think china was the big one to be honest
and now that that's kind of over um
obviously the european union would be
huge anything in the with the uk would
be huge but i i i just don't see those
markets cracking down
um so i there's nothing out there that
is like the big scary whale that we're
just waiting for that to happen like i
don't know of any other big countries if
anything we're seeing you know countries
now embracing cryptocurrency and making
it an accepted you know form of tender
like it's it's so that's happening which
is just fantastic
you